I hope they're they're very happy and it
lasts forever because of both beautiful
people Miley Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth
are back on but following their split in
2013 the singer was linked to Kellan
Lutz now he's setting the record
straight and he couldn't be happier for
Miley are you surprised that she's
ringing gaged are you happy for her I'm
very happy for ya
yeah we never dated it was all hearsay
and those are all gossip stuff and I'm
I'm so happy for her Liam I am so sorry
about it
it's something that I've even gone
through a relationships they can date
someone it's not necessarily healthy
because both people are growing and then
you kind of reconnect years later and
again I've been extremely busy traveling
the world and working but I hope they're
they're very happy and it lasts forever
because they're both beautiful people
inside of know now was that so these
days kelan is focused on his career his
newest movie extraction is action packed
and co-stars Bruce Willis the shots
I'm gonna have a threat my family it was
just a dream come true
Bruce Bruce is very good quiet very
slow-moving and particular but that's
what works you know it's the movie magic
he's a brilliant actor to work alongside
works in the movies